hey guys it's justine and i am so
excited because it is iphone season and
in front of me i have all four of the
brand new iphones we have the iphone 13
pro max the iphone 13 the iphone 13 pro
and the iphone 13 mini this is great
because last year the iphone pro max and
the mini were delayed so this year we
have all of them right here up front and
we're gonna unbox them all in this video
if you guys are new here hi welcome i do
a ton of tech videos here and we're
gonna have a bunch of apple content so
be sure to subscribe if you haven't
already hit the bell to receive
notifications and like this video and
leave a comment below if there's
anything that you would like to see us
test out with these phones
i still get so excited about this like
honestly and it's not just iphones like
it is actually just all technology like
it is so exciting for me that i just i
can't even explain it and i guess i
don't have to explain it because you can
see the pure joy on my face where should
we start first
tyler which one do you think should we
do you pick what should we do which one
do we do first no i think we'll do the
pink one i didn't even give you an
option i'm so sorry
this is more of like a baby pink color i
was hoping for a hot pink but honestly
pink is pink and i'm hyped about it so
let's check this out
okay so first of all this actually looks
way better than i thought it was going
to it's so hard when you see these
devices on a screen even for you guys
here in this video this actually looks
way better than it does on any photos
that i saw it's a very very subtle pink
here we go
oh it's so
clean i need to get a screen protector
on this immediately and of course in the
box we have no charging brick but that's
not new information and most carriers
have also followed suit so it's not just
apple that doesn't include chargers in
the box anymore and we've got our usbc 2
lightning cable so the first thing that
you're going to notice here with the 13
is the cameras are actually now diagonal
in the iphone 12 you can see they are
vertical so they did this to be able to
integrate in sensor shift technology so
it's much more stabilized instead of
just doing it inside of the camera and
using software so since we just unboxed
the larger iphone 12 we're just gonna go
into the brand new iphone 12 pro max
oh my god it's the 13.
all right let's go into the new iphone
13 pro max because this is the new color
this is the sierra blue and this looks
very
very pretty oh wow okay this is great
what i love about the pro max is they
have a more
i don't know what they are actually
calling it but it's kind of like a
frosted glass on the back as opposed to
the 13 it's more of a shiny whereas this
one is shiny but it's it's frosted so
sierra blue check
that out it's so pretty
[Music]
these camera bumps like
these are getting thick i can't wait to
try this out i'm so excited there's a
comparison between the 13 pro max and
the 12 pro max they do have a very
similar look but
i really like the look so i can't really
complain now time for the 13 pro in gold
let's check this out
[Music]
oh
this is a very nice gold it was so funny
because last year when they first
announced this gold color when i first
saw it online i was like i
do not like that gold at all and then i
ended up getting the gold phone and i
was like what was i thinking it's
beautiful because it's not like a super
aggressive gold it's just like a nice
gold hint it's really hard to tell like
you can barely even tell that this is
gold is this gold are my eyes no this is
gold this looks really great though i
really like it and it is a very subtle
gold so if that is something that you're
concerned with just know
very subtle let me show you in
comparison to the silver you can see the
slight slight shift i
can't believe that there's new iphones
out again i'm still kind of processing
that and last up but not least this is
the new iphone 13 mini and they did say
that you're going to be getting an
additional hour and a half battery life
with this which is amazing because i
think that was one of the biggest
complaints that a lot of people had was
the battery life on the iphone mini and
honestly like i love the iphone mini the
only reason that that wasn't my main
device is it didn't have the the
telephoto lens my
phone is used mostly for creating
content so i do need to have the best of
the best i mean i don't need to but like
i want to
this is the midnight color
it's so strange because it's very
it's very very dark like on camera like
this almost looks black but like when
i'm seeing this in person i don't even
know what this color is like a like a
greenish blue kind of like undertone to
it
man the mini is
just such a cool
phone like it's so small so powerful
and like it really is like the perfect
just fit this thing fits so well in my
yoga pants i always take this phone
hiking i take it running it's
perfect i love you i see it back
it's not turned on that's why okay so
here's our 2021 iphone lineup mini
regular pro max pro we also
have some accessories which is very
exciting these are review units i'm
never really sure like what's going to
show up so it really ends up being like
such a fun surprise so we got our iphone
13 mini case this is the color clover
here's the iphone 13 case this is like a
nice like salmon kind of color this is
actually also one of my favorite colors
we've got the leather iphone 13 pro case
that's gonna look really really nice and
then we've got our leather
pro max this is the midnight case
awesome that's gonna look really good
and we also have the leather iphone
wallet i'm very excited to test this out
wow that looks so good these colors
actually all look very good together
what a nice little color palette i'm so
excited all right leather wallet
let's see what you're all about there it
is check that out look at this look at
that
so where's the find my located how did
you do the thing that you did
[Music]
um like
tyler does this look like your uniform
very nice i really love magsafe and i'm
so excited they have a lot of really
great mag save colors for this this
season of iphones so now let's uh let's
turn these on
all right time to get these all set up i
love this little hello welcome
background kind of reminds me of the new
imax
hi i'm siri hi i'm siri choose the voice
you'd like me
you
hey how's the weather today hey we set a
timer for three minutes hey play some
music
[Music]
oh my gosh i just set up all four phones
at the same time why have i not done
this my entire
iphone career
hi brynn
hey brynn i'm making a youtube video
right now do you want to do you want to
meet someone new
that over there is tyler can you say
tyler say hi tyler thank you okay um i
have to go film because i'm in the
middle of making a youtube video bye
the baby knows how to go into contacts
and find the people she wants to call
she's not even two yet i just real
quickly let's see what that 3x zoom
looks like let's just see what we can do
oh
photographic styles so we can choose the
style that we want you can use standard
rich contrast vibrant warm
or cool and i just want to test the 3x
okay here we go and this is
the two and a half x so you can already
see that there is a zoom difference oh
man i'm so excited okay that's it for
this video the reviews will be coming
soon or they may already be up i'll put
links in the description and they'll be
linked here in the end card so that's
all for me
i gotta go play with my phones
[Music]
you